on a souhaité que la martinique soit
haute d'un événement car et bien qui est
en fait la petite soeur de du festival
que nous avons à paris que nous
organisons depuis maintenant environ 15
ans et donc là nous soit vous souhaitez
que cela martinique puisse être hôte
d'un grand événement culturel dont dédié
au gospel au niveau des invités cette
année
cette année nous avons une belle palette
parce qu'il s'agit évidemment d'une
grande pointure du gospel contemporain
israël à automne avec shevell franklyn
de la jamaïque
donc la caraïbe toujours à l'honneur et
puis toujours la chorale totale prise en
fond pour pouvoir apporter vraiment
cette couleur très très forte
nous avons une chorale qui sera à la
fois composé de choristes de la
martinique est aussi de paris pour faire
une grande grande belle formule pour
plus de cent choristes et musiciens sur
scène ça va vraiment être quelque chose
de très fort nous sommes heureux de
revenir à l'atrium puisqu'il y avait eu
difficultés pour être dans cette salle
et nous sommes très très heureux
qu'enfin la direction ait pu réaliser
combien le gospel est important pour
notre martinique pour la culture et que
cela représente par mois une musique qui
doit compter dans la caraïbe
comment vous expliquez cette notoriété
grandissante pour le gospel est bien le
gospel c'est une musique qui fait
adhésion c'est vrai que le gospel tout
simplement véhicule un message très fort
de paix de fraternité d'amour
un message qui donne la force de
transcender le quotidien toutes les
épreuves que l'on peut traverser et
c'est vrai que dans cette musique et
bien il y a le message le message de
l'évangile et c'est évidemment un
message qui traverse toutes les
barrières donc c'est une musique qui
prend de plus en plus de l'ampleur parce
que les gens finalement réalisent qu'ils
ne s'agit pas d'être dans quatre murs et
de vivre la religion mais de co2 croire
véritablement ce dieu là dans ce message
qui est qui est donné et puis aussi le
fait que cette musique apporte toutes
les tendances musicales
on ne retrouve dans le gospel à la fois
évidemment le negro-spiritual qui a
évolué vers le gospel mais on retrouve
aussi tout ce qui est art
bissol jazz donc on retrouve tous ses
accents la dent dans la musique gospel
contemporaine et donc les gens s'y
retrouvent très très adhère très
largement